fall in love with the dirt I
promise you everything you want is based
on the dirt the humility the patience
the accountability understanding and
empathy of others when they on you
that's all dirt talk this is dirt talk
this dirt top so
many of you are so interested in getting
to the penthouse and I promise you for
the real ones who love the building who
love the process who love the
game you will realize real quick it
doesn't taste as good up there it's not
as natural it's not as authentic
it's not as real the
dirt is where it's at and I will stay in
this dirt until the day I die
and then I'll go back into dirt
permanently these are the best days when
you're sweating from the Dome
when you don't even have to they're all
surprised you're doing it
understand
down here